[Music]  oh  [Music]  um  hi um can i get a bacon egg and cheese  on an everything bagel  [Music]  thank you  [Music]  bacon egg and cheese is such a classic  combination here and it goes so well  with a toasted bagel  is  you  [Music]  yogurt  [Music]  oh  awesome  is  [Music]  peanut banana and plant in porridge this  is something that most of us here enjoy  and quick to have in the morning  this tastes really good  feels really nice  [Music]  good  [Music]  good  funny  foreign  [Music]  how  uh  bye  make him sit up on me  me  what i like about the muhammadi is the  distinct taste of the coconut and  cardamom spice flavors they really give  it a unique taste and brings out the  truth so hilly food  that is mahamuri  so  is  foreign  foreign  [Music]  this is my breakfast it's a torta de  chilaquiles  it's delicious  [Music]  [Music]  you